[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce jeudi 24 mai il
réunit des équipes de pompiers de france
et du monde l'extraction challenge 2018
a débuté aujourd'hui au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
une compétition sur trois jours de
secours routier de secours d'urgence aux
personnes nous serons sur place dans un
instant musulmans chrétiens juifs et
élus locaux rassemblés pour rompre le
jeûne du ramadan la rencontre était
organisée hier à coignières un moment de
partage à l'initiative du collectif des
associations musulmanes de saint quentin
en yvelines
et puis à rambouillet la bergerie
nationale accueille ce week-end le salon
des métiers d'art 53 exposants des
démonstrations et conférences au
programme présentation avec florence
dupont à vitrailliste et secrétaire de
l'association qui organise cet événement
on parlera dans ce journal également de
la fête de la nature qui se tient en ce
moment l'établissement du chapeau
tremblay sur mauldre organise à cette
occasion une journée d'animations ce
samedi mais doivent d'abord je vous en
parlais dans les titres le début
aujourd'hui de l'extraction challenge
durant trois jours 19 équipes de toute
la france mais aussi du monde
s'affrontent dans des épreuves
d'extraction d'accidentés de la route
objectif qualification pour les
championnats d' internationaux en
afrique du sud sur place ce matin pour
le début de la compétition
marylène iapichino
les accidents spectaculaires en plein
centre du vélodrome de montigny le
bretonneux des pompiers de toute la
france se sont donné rendez vous pour
montrer leurs meilleures techniques de
désincarcération et de prise en charge
des accidentés de la route ce matin
l'équipe des alpes-maritimes tenter de
relever le challenge
elle avait un cas très difficile avec
deux personnes qui étaient incarcérés
dans la voiture retournée sur le toit
ils se sont bien débrouillés dix neuf
équipes françaises et trois équipes
internationales sont venus participer à
cette troisième édition la compétition
tourne autour de deux épreuves 10
minutes pour extraire une victime
trente minutes quand il y en a deux un
véritable travail d'équipé
orchestré par les capitaines samedi le
partage de la connaissance autour du
monde sap accompli la désincarcération
c'est un objectif qui est porté depuis
des dizaines une dizaine d'années au
travers le monde la france s'est inscrit
dans
cette technique depuis trois ans pour la
première fois cette année le département
d évident à sa propre équipe
les huit pompiers se sont entraînés
depuis le mois de janvier pour ces
épreuves prévues vendredi et samedi
c'est une envie ça fait partie de nos
missions aussi de tous les jours en cas
de sapeurs pompiers ça demande un petit
peu de technique l'utilisation de
matériel et puis aussi un petit peu de
réflexion au niveau des accidents de la
route par l'événement est ouvert au
public et pour l'occasion un espace
prévention est mise en place à
l'extérieur
deux mille cinq cents collégiens et
lycéens yvelinois sont sensibilisés aux
risques de la route à travers différents
simulateurs
histoire de rappeler qu'avant le
désincarcérer mieux vaut éviter
l'accident
[Musique]
on leur fait prendre conscience de leur
fragilité
à un âge où ils se sentent vraiment très
très fort et ou deviennent de plus en
plus c'est pourquoi ils prennent
davantage de risques et c'est pourquoi
malheureusement les jeunes de 15-24 ans
sont deux fois plus sinistrées sur la
route que les autres tranches d'âge
le challenge extraction des sapeurs
pompiers se poursuit jusqu'à samedi le
vainqueur se qualifiera pour le
championnat mondial cette année en
afrique du sud et on trouvera dans un
instant au direct sur place michael et
demi d'euros depuis le vélodrome
nationale elle les pompiers qui étaient
hier mercredi sur le terrain de la
couldre à montigny le bretonneux leur
sélection nationale de rugby en blanc
sur les images affrontait celle de la
police nationale deuxième édition de ce
match caritatif au profit d' orphée
paulo d'orphéopolis et de l'oder pl2
oeuvre qui accompagnent les orphelins et
les familles des sapeurs pompiers et
policiers l ensemble des fonds récoltés
a été ainsi reversé à ces deux
associations
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude malheureusement on est des
professions à risque quand même
effectivement tous les ans il ya des
nous collègues qu il y décède en
intervention ou war intervention
effectivement ces oeuvres la prennent en
charge les orphelins et inscrit que la
famille là les parents qui restent de
manière à les aider à continuer dans la
vie normale
l'enjeu était évidemment bien ailleurs
mais la rencontre s'est terminée en tout
cas sur le score de 26 partout et on
reparle de sport plus tard dans cette
édition
c'est un moment important pour les
musulmans durant le mois de ramadhan
l'iftar la rupture du jeûne après le
coucher de soleil un moment de
convivialité partagé hier par différents
représentants de culte locaux à
coignières c'était à l'invitation du
collectif des associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des élus
étaient également présents pour ces
échanges
le reportage de nicolas kirillovitch et
patrick jacques de dixmude chrétiens
juifs musulmans et des personnalités
politiques tous réunis le temps d'une
soirée
l'image est hautement symbolique rendu
possible grâce au dîner organisé par le
collectif des musulmans de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses
environs pour une rupture du jeûne
inter-religieuse à un moment de partage
unique a favorablement accueilli par les
représentants des différentes
confessions c'est important que l'on
puisse avoir des relations suffisamment
forte et puis que l'on se connaisse
c'est ça qui est important
on n'est pas dans la réflexion de fond
de théologie le débat de société etc
mais dans l'amitié marchent ensemble
c'est de ce tissu social et de ses
rapports entre associations musulmanes
pouvoirs publics et autres associations
cultuelles des autres cultes sur des
petits territoires qui mis bout à bout
créer une légitimité au collectif que je
préside le cam 68
pas de grands discours ni de débats
enflammés donc pour ce dîner mais la
volonté de favoriser les échanges locaux
des personnalités politiques étaient
également présentes pour ce rendez vous
inscrit dans un contexte national tendu
c'est vrai que dans cette période un peu
compliquée avec le terrorisme islamiste
eh bien il est important que nous les
responsables politiques
montre bien qu'il faut séparer le bon
grain de l'ivraie
c'est bien que chacun ait exprimé
les valeurs auxquelles nous tiens
avec chacun sait leurs paroissiens le
cam 78 proposer ce rendez vous pour la
troisième année consécutive le collectif
regroupe au total treize associations
sur le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines essaye on l'a retrouvé michael
ennemis de roches et en direct depuis le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'extraction
au challenge qui se tient pendant trois
jours nickel on a vu le sujet en début
de journal alors c'est un événement qui
tourne autour de la compétition mais
aussi autour de la prévention et la
pédagogie
vous êtes d'ailleurs mutuel devant un
bus qui simulent des tonneaux
effectivement un grégory relais voiture
tonneau vous connaissiez bien sûr et là
derrière moi il ya un bus qui bascule
tout simplement pour m'en parler
le capitaine emmanuel b q qui est avec
moi justement le puits c'est en train de
basculer derrière nous qu'est-ce qui se
passe nous sommes devant un quart
pédagogie qui simule un basculement deux
objectifs le premier sensibiliser les
personnes au port de la ceinture de
sécurité
le deuxième leur permettre de comprendre
et les flécher concernant une évacuation
d'un bus ayant basculé quand même
basculement vous avez fait aujourd'hui
j'imagine beaucoup nous sommes à peu
près à une quarantaine de basculement
effectivement avec le millier de
scolaires qui étaient présents sur site
c'était une des attractions très prisé
quel est l'objectif du coût de ce
basculement
donc l'objectif de ce basculement est de
bien montrer aux scolaires les
sensibiliser au port de la ceinture de
sécurité
chose qui n'est pas toujours faite lors
des transports scolaires il a
aujourd'hui le deuxième objectif
l'objectif était également de leur
montrer comment on fait une évacuation
d'un bus et leurs basques et les
scolaires également ont pu boire
d'autres animations il y en a une
trentaine un sursis temps donc les
scolaires ont pu participer une
trentaine d'animations toutes plus
innovantes les unes que les autres
notamment des voiture tonneau des
voitures crash tsd piste de sécurité
routière afin de leur prendre conscience
des dangers de la route
n'oublions pas que ce sont les
générations futures il faut aujourd'hui
les éduquer les informer à la prévention
routière a pu voir également quelques
vidéos ils ont également vu des vidéos
nous ont fait
milieu de la piste de compétition une
vidéo afin de leur permettre de réagir
interactivement avec leur smartphone sur
les conduites à tenir en cas d'accident
après c'est pour les scolaires mais pas
forcément que les scolaires a également
des personnes lambda qui veulent venir
sur site peuvent peuvent le faire la
zone de prévention et bien évidemment
ouvert à tout public
la prévention et la sécurité routière
c'est un sujet d'actualité qui n'est pas
dédiée aux scolaires tout public et
bienvenue sur notre zone de prévention
et on peut voir tout ça jusqu'à quand
jusqu'à ce samedi jusqu'à samedi 17
heures au vélodrome olympique de
montigny-le-bretonneux
voilà vous connaissez tous maintenant à
grégory 1 sur ce puits ce tonneau et
toutes les animations qui sont autour de
cet événement merci à vous amical est
également à camille lambert hoa moyens
techniques
hier mercredi s'est tenue la première
édition du à paris saclay spring un
rendez vous dédié à l'innovation avec la
présentation a notamment du projet et
smart cities imaginé par bouygues
énergie et services implantées sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il s'agit d'un hyperviseur urbain
destiné à connecter et pilotés à
distance tous les équipements d'une
ville que ce soit l'éclairage public ou
encore la vidéoprotection il sera
bientôt opérationnelle à dijon écouter
cette interview collectées au micro d'
or ils iront et manon varaldo donner un
exemple si on a un accident de la
circulation
il va falloir passer les faits en
clignotant dans la ville il va falloir
rallumer l'éclairage va falloir baisser
les bornes
donc tout ça on va pouvoir le faire
depuis un seul outil et de façon très
synchronisée en très peu de temps quand
d'habitude il faut ouvrir un logiciel
différent
ap les différents interlocuteurs aux
intervenants pour qu'ils réalisent ces
actions on vous en parlait hier dans ce
journal au prisme d'elancourt le prisme
d'elancourt accueillait ce jeudi est la
troisième édition du challenge de
robotique skis robe est le concept plus
de 1000 élèves de la maternelle au bts
ont programmé à des robots à leurs
machines leur machine doit réussir à
boucler des parcours cette année le
rendez vous était focalisée sur la ryder
cup michael ni d'euros et manon varaldo
des robots déguisée des supporters
enthousiastes du stress bienvenue la
troisième édition du challenge de
robotique sky robe en arrivant les 1000
élèves de 40 établissements n'ont qu'un
objectif en tête prouver qu'ils ont
programmé leur robot part
ils ont envie de gagner effectivement il
ya quand même une compétition et c'est
pour ça aussi qui l'on est et en motiver
toute l'année pour faire des efforts
pour progresser pour résoudre les bugs
c'est bien parce qu'il ya une
compétition donc du coup un vrai projet
derrière
tous ont travaillé sur un cahier des
charges élaboré en lien avec l'éducation
nationale le thème la ryder cup 2018 qui
se tiendra en septembre à saint quentin
en yvelines
un jury spécialisé composé d'une dizaine
de personnes s'est chargé de noter cette
partie de mini golf 2.0 il s'est un
petit peu délicat parce qu'on sent
qu'ils ont travaillé ils peuvent être
parfois déçu parce que ça fonctionne pas
comme il le voudrait parce que les
conditions sont pas les mêmes qu'à
l'école évidemment les robots réagissent
pas toujours pareil il ya des pannes
parfois ils n'arrivent pas les démarré
voilà des mésaventure qu'ont connus ses
élèves d'écoles primaires de trappes
c'est vraiment décevant parce que n'a
vraiment travailler et on avait on avait
réussi j'ai servant de venir on avait
bien réussi mais maintenant
c'est ma il ya des petits soucis ça
permet aux enfants aussi d'avoir le
droit à l'erreur donc on l'a vu
aujourd'hui ils sont préparés à ça ils
savent que le robot il n'avance pas tout
seul il faut le programmer avant sur un
logiciel
d'autres au contraire ont vu leurs
investissements de l'année récompense et
c'est grâce au travail de l'école
enfin de travailler travailler on arrive
c'est parce qu'on a rue salle pour
ramener bien à bien le programme et le
challenge the sky robe reviendra l'année
prochaine pour une quatrième édition la
thématique devrait être annoncée en
septembre prochain et jusqu'au 27 mai
c'est la fête de la nature des
animations se déroulent partout en
france pour cette douzième édition sur
le thème de voir l'invisible un bon soir
laurent carle vous êtes le chef
d'établissement du centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion qui est
situé au tremblay sur mauldre alors le
chef fait cette nature fait la nature le
samedi 26 mai à de nombreux ateliers
pratiques et stands gratuits seront
proposés on va en parler dans un instant
peut-être déjà un mot sur le chef c'est
un établissement privé sous contrat et
il propose des formations qui sont
tournés vers le paysage et
l'environnement vers l'environnement le
paysage et la forêt depuis peu voilà il
fit la gloire mans donc un grand bonjour
à tous et c'est vrai que nous avons le
plaisir chaque année depuis bon nombre
d'années de nous associer à cet
événement national et on va dire que
c'est une logique puisque
l'établissement de par ses formations à
une prégnance toute particulière sur
l'environnement et sur la position de la
nature est un site aussi exceptionnel 21
hectares
en pleine nature cet établissement est
situé en pleine nature c'est tout à fait
exact
et c'est 21 heures nous permettent de
mener nos formations de la 3è 4è lancer
mon école jusqu'au bac
aménagement du paysage bach fauré est
aussi bach des gestions de la gestion
des mines nature et de la faune en passe
en retrait pour terminer sur un bts
brevet technicien supérieur gestion et
protection de la nature sans oublier le
bts également aménagement du paysage
envoyer autant de formations diverses et
variées qui permettent à bon nombre de
jeunes chaque année d'une part de
ressortir de chez nous avec un diplôme
mais également de trouver une insertion
professionnelle à la clé
oui finalement c'est assez large avait
du collège après le bac il ya plusieurs
exactement et la spécificité de notre
établissement c'est que nous avons fait
3 3 entités de formation d'information
au procès avec continue pour les adultes
un cfa donc centre de formation par
apprentissage et l'école du savoir vert
pour la partie et lycées sous contrat
avec le ministère de la culture mais
vous disiez tout à l'heure que
l'établissement s'associent plus depuis
plusieurs années à cette fête de la
nature c'est tout à fait normal quand on
est un établissement dédié à la nature
de s'associer à cette fête
oui d'autant plus que l'idée dans l'une
de nos cinq missions de l'enseignement
agricole
c'est justement d'être acteurs du
territoire et notamment sur
l'accompagnement la sensibilisation sur
des thématiques nationales et on sait ô
combien aujourd'hui l'environnement et
la protection de la nature sont des
thématiques enjeux nationaux et voire
même mondiaux vous avez l'impression
aujourd'hui qu'on s'éloigne de la nature
c'est tout le contraire peut-être on va
dire que on peut noter plusieurs
reprises de des paradoxes important à
plusieurs égards
on peut avoir avec notre approche
sociétale qui vise à plus à l'est en
zone urbaine ou semi urbaines
donc une tendance ressentie de
s'éloigner la nature mais on constate
parallèlement que c'est bien souvent des
56 citoyens aux concitoyens qui sont
dans ces zones là qui sont par ailleurs
sensible voire très sensibles à des
domaines de protection de
l'environnement car sur les objectifs de
cette journée samedi on imagine fêter la
nature sensibiliser peut-être les plus
petits à ce thème aussi les adultes
s'est aussi montré toutes les
possibilités de l'établissement faire
peut-être sa promotion
alors c'est vrai qu' on est pleinement
associés à la fête de la nature on en
profite en même temps pour faire une
journée portes ouvertes donc le grand
public forcément orienté du coup vers le
recrutement et d'éventuels famille ou
jeunes qui souhaiteraient bien sûr venir
s'inscrire mais c'est vrai que dans la
continuité de ce que nous pouvons déjà
être amené à faire au sein des collèges
en fait n'intervenons bien souvent au
sein du collège notamment les bts et
dans le cadre de leur formation qui vise
un domaine plus particulièrement sur
l'accueil et l'animation du public et
ben nous intervenons auprès de jeunes
publics voire très jeune public pour les
sensibiliser dès le premier âge à ces
enjeux et thématiques et notion de
l'environnement et de la protection de
la nature
alors il ya un programme très complet
pour cette journée au chef samedi une
trentaine d'animations gratuites pour
tous les goûts il ya des choses aussi
bien pour les enfants mais aussi pour
les adultes
voilà on va dire qu'on va pas bien sûr
dévoiler tous les éléments vous pourrez
être amené à rencontrer on veut nous
voir ce samedi alors déjà en
introduction il annonce très beau temps
donc si vous voulez le climat nous
accompagnera sur rendez-vous sera au
rendez vous voilà après on a bien sûr
un certain nombre d'activités qui seront
en lien avec la thématique nationale
annuelle de la fête de la nature
et cette année c'est voir l'invisible
alors si vous voyez la question peut se
poser déjà comment peut-on voir
l'invisible et donc à ce titre et bien
nous avons réalisé organisé un certain
nombre d'animations qui tourneront
autour de cette thématique là je n'en
dis pas plus mais voilà on va parler de
2,2 microscope électronique par exemple
mais aussi de loupes binoculaires il est
aussi aujourd'hui dans la nature les
forces les forces de la nature qui paul
nous anime et sans qu'on les voit par
ailleurs et donc il ya des découvertes
sur cette thématique là qui seront de
fait aussi intéressant pour les jeunes
que pour les adultes
on l'a compris quelques surprises samedi
il ya un programme aussi et qui a établi
par exemple une mini ferme pédagogique
qui sera proposé également un concours
de pêche alors concours de pêche unis
ferment
l'idée si vous voulez c'est que pour
sensibiliser au mieux les jeunes à cette
thématique là on se rend compte que de
pouvoir parler du concret de pouvoir à
leur montrer des animaux des insectes
des amphibiens des batraciens à des
tout-petits et ben par soi même on
n'arrive pas à passer un certain nombre
de notions qui sont importantes par la
suite donc bien sûr effectivement une
présence d'animaux faune flore sur sur
le site et on n'oublie pas non plus que
nous sommes rattachés à la ligue de
protection des oiseaux et donc si tel
pays où depuis quelques
années déjà et en cela on a du coup pu
organiser un lieu pour pouvoir observer
avec jumelles et où lon vu un certain
nombre d'oiseaux
voilà donc des activités qui se rend de
fait très attrayante pour la plupart du
public et à ce titre on a même pour tout
vous dire des élus qui viendront nous
voir et je pense tout particulièrement à
des à des mères et vous même des députés
donc voilà c'est assez large en termes
doha que cette journée peut avoir pour
notre établissement précise important
que le public peut venir avec son pique
nique exactement si vous voulez vous le
disais tout à l'heure 21 hectares avec
un grand à rebours et heures une
arboretum pardon une belle roseraie et
donc avec le beau temps qui sera présent
et ben je ne peux qu'inviter les uns les
autres à venir passer la journée à nos
côtés merci à laurent tir d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous chef
d'établissement du chef et le programme
complet de cette fête de la nature au
shape est à retrouver donc sur le site
internet qui s'affiche à l'écran je
rappelle qu'elle se déroule ce samedi
football ce soir on joue la finale de la
ligue des champions féminine l'olympique
lyonnais affronte wolfsburg la pratique
féminine qui est en plein essor dans le
département le district est des yvelines
a enregistré cette année 9 % de
licenciés supplémentaires aux magny
football club une section féminine vient
de voir le jour une journée découverte
était proposée samedi dernier au stade
de la pointe de chute d'un cours manon
varaldo nicolas landry connaître le
positionnement de son corps par rapport
au ballon travail sur la technique
conduite de balle match ou encore
ateliers tir tel était le programme de
la journée découverte de la section
féminine du magny football club
on a envie de relancer le football
féminin sur manille on est convaincu du
potentiel de joueuses qui peut y avoir
sur la commune et les communes
avoisinantes
cette année on se donne notre challenge
de remonter une section pour la saison
prochaine aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on fait
c'est pas pour se regarder
c'est à dire qu'on aura trois quatre
joueuses dont on espère vraiment créer
une section féminine avec une ou deux
équipes dans différentes catégories
aujourd'hui la pratique féminine est en
pleine expansion en quatre ans
le nombre de licenciés a doublé dans les
yvelines mais le football reste
catalogué pour beaucoup comme un sport
dit masculin au grand désespoir des
futures joueuses de magny les hameaux
c'était intéressant ya on n'a pas du
football féminin ici et bah parce que le
football féminin s'est pas à jouer
partout et c'est par se développer
je vois pas pourquoi on profite et je
serai plus les garçons que les filles
cdu comme ça ça peut être sexiste
merci avec cette journée découverte en
dépassant les stéréotypes des passion
pour le football sont nés là-bas c'est
jouer avec elle les autres et après
l'âge au foot
j'aime bien faire des passes et est trop
gros
avis aux amatrices la prochaine session
découverte du football féminin du club
de manille se déroulera le 2 juin au
stade de la pointe de chemin cours à 16
heures avant de clôturer ce journal
c'est un événement qui a lieu ce
week-end à rambouillet le salon des
métiers d'art se tient samedi et
dimanche à la bergerie nationale
c'est dans les granges de la cour royale
53 exposants seront présents
bonsoir florence dupont vous êtes
vitrailliste basée à dourdan en essonne
secrétaire de l'association des artisans
d'art et de laver les chevreuse qui
organise ce salon alors présenté nous
déjà cette association quelles sont ces
luttes ses missions donc l'association
des artisans d'art existe depuis 2002 et
notre mission est de promouvoir les
métiers d'art sur le territoire de la
vallée de chevreuse et donc pour ça nous
organisations nous organisons des
expositions des salons deux fois par an
et
à l'automne au printemps cette fois nous
sommes donc accueilli à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet ça c'est la
première fois lors ce salon n'est pas
une première mais en tout cas le fait
d'être à la bergerie nationale c'est une
première exactement
voilà jusqu'à présent on a longuement
été à châteaufort en yvelines au moulin
d'or ce mais voilà pour la première fois
nous sommes donc à la bergerie nationale
la bergerie un haut lieu d'histoire mais
aussi pour l'artisanat la laine mérinos
s'est développée à partir de de cette
bergerie nationale de rambouillet en
tout cas en france
j'imagine ça revêt une importance
particulière d'être présentés très
heureux d'être accueilli la base c'est
un beau lieu évidemment avec beaucoup d
espace
donc les exposants seront gâtés et le
public aussi pour venir regarder donc
tout au long du week-end nous allons
avoir des démonstrations mais en fait de
nombreux métiers sont représentés
le travail du bois du verre le travail
du cuir de la céramique donc beaucoup
beaucoup de métiers du des bijoutiers
des ébénistes ont essayé à 53 exposants
c'est un panorama global vos l'artisanat
baril en sorte de choisir de nombreux
métiers le plus le plus large possible
et donc les exposants qui seront là
donneront des démonstrations de leur
métier donc à partir de samedi jusqu'à
dimanche en fait toute la journée
de 15 heures à 18 heures vous aurez des
démonstrations pour voir comment ces
artisans travaillent avec quels
matériaux quels outils quelles sont
leurs techniques quels sont leurs savoir
faire
on est sur du made in france absolument
oui sas a de beaux jours devant lui
vivement ce oui bien sûr on est là pour
ça en tout cas c'est la mission de notre
association qui est de promouvoir les
métiers d'art et de faire en sorte que
voilà ça puisse s'ouvrir au grand public
alors plus possible vous notamment
présentes parmi ses 53 exposants vous
est vitrailliste je le rappelle parlez
nous un peu de votre activité qu'elle
quel type de réalisations faites vous
donc moi je travaille
voilà je crée des vitraux je travaille
pour des privés et des publics en
création contemporaine
donc voilà c'est un métier qui cas de
longues années derrière lui mais qui
peut être revisitée au goût du jour
c'est ce que je fais d'accord donc voilà
d'ailleurs certaines de vos réalisations
à l'écran vous avez dit des
démonstrations des des conférences aussi
alors on fait des démonstrations des
conférences donc on va avoir de la
vannerie une personne qui est des savons
de la sellerie réfection de sièges
réfection de tableau donc voilà ce sera
très intéressant pour pour tout public
en fait
dernière question pour une édition
réussie quels ingrédients doivent être
réunies ce week-end alors battle
enthousiasme et puis de la joie de
partager nos métiers en fait ce salon
des métiers d'art je rappelle qu'il est
au programme samedi et dimanche à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet rendez
vous de 10 heures à 19 heures précision
importante l'entrée est libre gratuite
et pour plus d'information et un site
internet un site internet de l'invs de
votre association pardon qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci florence dupont
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle
secrétaire de cette association qui
organise cet évènement et vous êtes
également vitrailliste à dourdan en
essonne voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
à suivre dans un instant un nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat et cette édition
elle est bien sûr à revoir sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]